Tom the reason I never went into
athletics and I'm gonna be totally
upfront with you hey I didn't get a lot
of you know I didn't get a lot of
encouragement but also I was nervous in
the locker room being nude honestly I
don't want guys to see my penis was that
ever an issue for you do you ever sit
there and go you know in the beginning
like I don't like not comfortable being
nude in front of other dudes and seeing
their penises now you figure it out
every guy's penis looks the exact same
so tiny things you just I mean you're
telling me gras looks like an ax man but
you're saying Gronk didn't have like the
biggest Swan on the planet Gronk is I
mean guys like a Greek god his body and
that guy's just jacked up it's actually
funny because I think they still let
reporters into the locker room so it
would be funny because Gronk would get
naked and literally throw his towel over
his shoulder and just walk through the
locker room with all the reporters that
I would just laugh because you know
Gronk obviously he didn't give a [ __ ]
but he's a strut through
you